of the commission for a good discussion
and during the yesterday and today with
the Finnish government Finland we work
closely with the Commission so that we
can implement the priorities of the
presidency program in particular we want
to cooperate in climate action issues
such as the climate neutrality target -
for 2050 Finland want to discuss climate
actions in several accounts in
configurations we consider if it's very
important that he you can speak with one
voice and agree that on the twenty five
twenty fifty we will also begin
negotiations with the EU member states
of the next Milton annual of finance of
Cambridge framework the Commission has
made a proposal on M F F F and Finland
will actively take forward negotiations
on the operative objectives programmes
and the level of EU funding as a
presidency we will also continue
discussions of the accession of the new
member states to the European Union
Finland has always been a friend to of
enlargement and assumes that when the
applicant countries meet the object
shape criteria they are welcome to join
in EU in this progress we really we rely
on that assessments of the Commission on
the progress made by the applicant
countries at the last point I would take
up I would like to thank President
Juncker and the Commission for the
efforts in developing of an adaptive
strategy for the EU so art accretion
faces challenges and offer opportunities
opportunities and the European needs to
develop a policy for our four Arctic
thank you
please prime minister ladies and
gentlemen it's a pleasure to be here
today in house Enki for the start of the
Finnish presidency it is true that
Finland often as the coldest climate you
know but it always has the warmest
hospitality I was witnessing this
yesterday night and the first time I was
able to admire the finish and
hospitality was in 1999 that was the
first Finnish presidency European
Council in Tampa were first informal
Finnish equal finding to ku with Saudi
Minister on taxation 20 years ago we
made some progress but he was very angry
with me at that time I will always
remember this specialist hands of Saudis
hospitality it's good to have to finish
presidency now because European Union
dramatically needs leadership and
stability which are qualities of my
Finnish friends a particular qualities
of auntie so we will benefit in
abundance from this Finnish qualities I
I think that we have good reasons to be
optimistic when we are starting the
Finnish presidency because Finland has
proven itself a leader in our union
behaving like a founding member whereas
founding members are not always behaving
like founding members because Finland
has always chosen the European path and
the second reason why I am optimistic is
linked to a Finnish concept
which is easy to pronounce but very
difficult to translate taco is about a
community working together as friends
and neighbors does the common goal and
this is exactly what we need in the
months ahead because we want to
implement our strategic priorities you
need Finland because Finland is
experience is prophetic earth cool had
it and that's exactly what we need in
the next coming months if we just visit
the optimist
low-skill Sergey did be on FA the social
it and any monkey fed day for don't know
some of the de Logitech dear Logitech
European there is no por la rocca
maggiore pop was a the sake indeed work
socio a focus is shot let's assume
conducive ok DJ past music uniform
Andrew and web sociology would weigh
consumer commission the prisoners fan on
disciplic a mathematic this Sahadev ok
Hodgman climatic LA in Los Feliz
administer to their model climatic would
love it control is not automatic
indigent activity the presence penalties
single continued no Aviv will come to
vivo
news on the map is when the capital
planet or
planet Nouveau South Guard a cell can
reserve on the refrigerator
argon T dot pland ATM beaucoup ask an
efficient TC Dermot on sank
attend today's objective condone fix a
pass not channel death it what is the
definitive man ate a brick at this
admission count dropped what a traumatic
mom no a laugh a lot mantra map with
reference climatic monitor will trans
executing a mission who probably
presence parentage over associate a
final judgment departure budget period
evanthia that with to the declared a
curve of the clock Montes not
responsible the forked with estimate of
Ramadan plus to dramatic
thank you thank you very much and now we
have time for a few questions and we
start with Helsingin Sanomat and the our
own heart a guy named please your
Nordica el cine someone with the
question do president Jukka earlier this
week the EU member-states finally agreed
on the nominations for the EU top jobs
but the process was very painful so I'd
like to hear your thoughts on the
process how smoothly the wind and
probably if you think that there's a
need to reform the process in the future
in some way thank you yes the process
was not very transparent but the process
which led to my nomination in 2014 was
very transparent because we had lead
candidates everyone knew what will
happen if this party or that party would
be the strongest part in the European
Parliament its revision to come back to
what unfortunately didn't become a
tradition I said in the European Council
the other day that I always had the
impression that I would enter history
but not like that because I'm a very
unique guy I was
first and the last pitch God promised
would you like to come in this no they
will take the second question and Susana
Tyrone and wireless Broadcasting Company
Wiley mr. young car did you talk at all
about the situation in our whole refugee
camp and do you see the the situation of
the children and the the women is an
issue for all of Europe or not and also
Prime Minister on terrain when will our
government do something about those
finished citizens down there I would say
that we had under this month under these
years we have tried to make us clear
what is the situation in a camp and now
we are with the internet within the
National Organization discussed how we
can help those terrorists on the camp
and it is a very complicated situation
when it comes to the rule of law and and
then when it comes to the situation real
situation of those people they are
instead of camp we have to follow human
rights and agreements which we are which
we have accepted but we also need to
secure the Finnish people who lives here
in Finland that security needs to be
security same respond what is a
privately Finland does apply to the
whole of the opinion
and then we have the third question was
Antonia berry mtv3 news
what did you discuss about this
five-year budget program here what
concrete things when you will you
represent sums and so on some examples
what we what kind of discussions we have
there was discussion about how to link
the rule of law and the financing on the
MFF and another thing is how how we can
support why I am Ivette climate fight
against climate changing and that kind
of things when we are when we talk about
mff was an open discussion then we have
the last question for the penis news
agency SDT from the finnish news agency
my questions question regards the whole
refugee camp in Syria shouldn't therapy
is some sort of coordinated EU wide
policy instead of every member state
having their own solutions and actions
and why has it been so difficult for the
you member states to come up with a
coordinated policy on this matter there
are people from what many countries on a
camp and they are not there is they
can't freely go out from a camp they are
under investigation of crimes many of
them and that improves so that it is not
so that we can drive or go there instead
of camera take people away that's one
one big question to understand that
Syria and Iraq has Iran has Iraq has
possibilities to
they wanted to have possibility to
investigate the crimes which has may be
done under this is his years and that's
why I think it is not easy to call
innate because there is private people
which comes from quite many countries
and they are not the similar situation
is people in inside the cab
do you want to comment this ok thank you
very much everyone
have a nice day